so I'm sitting in my office and in the
other room I hear what it's my fiancee
and I'm like what's wrong what's wrong
and she's like Robert Pattinson is
rumored to play Indiana Jones and in
that very moment I had to kind of just
sit there and breathe because my heart
it was not working briefly and let me
stress the word rumored there is a rumor
going around Hollywood right now that
Robert Pattinson you may know him as
Edward Cullen from the Twilight films is
a frontrunner to replace Harrison Ford
as Indiana Jones in future installments
like I said rumor this is a rumor by the
time I post this video Robert Pattinson
could come out and be like yeah that's
not true Thanks and so you may be
thinking why are you making this video
because it's not confirmed in the past I
have done videos when Ben Affleck was
confirmed as Batman or Jesse Eisenberg
was confirmed as Lex Luthor the fact the
matter is I've gotten a lot of requests
to talk about the fact that Indiana
Jones could be rebooted one day and
talked about people that I feel may be
good in that role because it is kind of
looking like Disney is going to treat
that as a James Bond like franchise on
top of that tomorrow Cinemark theatres
across the nation are showing Raiders of
the Lost Ark in theaters and I'm going
to be going to see that so this is a
perfect time for me to talk about
Indiana Jones now let me get this out
there Robert Pattinson I don't think
he's a bad actor I do not dislike Robert
Pattinson I don't hate the guy I just
think that he was saddled with one of
the most made fun of franchises in film
history and no one in those films were
good no one can give good performances
when they're reading dialogue like the
fetus has been compromised you can't say
that and actually give a good
performance you're gonna suck no matter
what so I'm not making this video to
hate on Robert Pattinson despite the
fact that I don't think he'd be a good
choice for the role of Indiana Jones
simply because I don't think I'd buy him
as a physical presence he doesn't seem
like the kind of person who could be
intimidating physically like he would do
his own stunts and things that would
sell the role of this hardened character
people in the past have been rumored
like Bradley Cooper or Chris Pine these
are people I can see performing this
role much more I can see them having a
gruff physicality to them that would
definitely work for the character of
Indiana Jones in a perfect world we
would have one
or Indiana Jones film with Harrison Ford
directed by Steven Spielberg produced by
George Lucas that's actually really good
that gives him the proper send-off that
he deserves that doesn't look like it's
going to happen though because Harrison
Ford is now kind of contractually
obligated to this new Star Wars thing
that's going on which is awesome and I'm
extremely excited about that and he is
getting up there in age and the hard
part about making Indiana Jones film is
that three men have to be in the exact
same place at the exact same time with
the free time and all agree Spielberg
Lucas and Ford they all have to be like
yep this is what we want to do could
Robert Pattinson be good in this role
maybe I just don't really feel like he
would sell the physicality of the
character I've seen him in movies beyond
Twilight where I thought he did a fine
job I don't actually think he's a bad
actor I just think that he was
unfortunately kind of involved with this
franchise Twilight that kind of gave him
this bad image yes it made him well
known and probably filled up his pockets
with quite a bit of money but his image
now is ruined by that he's made it quite
clear how he actually feels about the
films if you just watch him in any
interviews so like I said in a perfect
world that's how Indiana Jones five
would happen we would have the proper
send-off it would be amazing it would be
enthralling it'd be a cool story be a
good script and it would be great but I
don't know if that's going to happen I
do think some of the actors like Bradley
Cooper or Chris Pine who have been
mentioned our good choice is to replace
this role because let's face it things
like this are going to happen as we grow
up certain things that we love from our
childhood that are very popular will
probably be reboot it in some way shape
or form and we're gonna have to deal
with that I'm a humongous Indiana Jones
fan so me just saying that it's like
it's like tears tears are forming but
it's gonna happen one day is it gonna be
Robert Pattinson I really truly hope not
not because I hate him as an actor I
just don't think he'd really be the good
actor for the part what are your guys
thoughts on this rumor more than likely
it's just gonna stay a rumor cuz it just
seems so ludicrous to me you know
doesn't seem like this would actually
happen but if it did happen I guess that
would be interesting and I would wait
many years in intense worry for the film
to come out and more than likely cry a
few times and not go hide in the corner
let me know your thoughts below and as
always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like the
you can click right here and get stuck
my next just a quick reminder my
promotion with audible is still
continuing these guys have been so
awesome through them you can download an
audiobook for free of your choice I
downloaded Stephen King's new book dr.
sleep narrated by will Patton Stephen
King is my favorite author and through
them I've been able to listen to a lot
of really awesome stuff and they have
contacted me and wanted me to reach out
to you guys to offer you guys a free
audiobook if you want to it's it's so
cool it's just free of charge you know
you just can go there and listen to any
book you want you can do it on your
tablet your phone on the go if you're
jogging on a plane anywhere in the car
anytime anyplace it's very convenient go
to audible.com slash Chris that's
audible.com slash Chris for your free
audiobook download courtesy of me from
audible thanks guys